yesterday I announced the launch of a
sixty thousand dollar crowdfunded
fundraiser we are one day in to that
sixty thousand dollar fund raiser day
one saw nearly a hundred donations as
small as two dollars three people
donating two dollars each thank you but
big Lee and we saw the biggest donations
coming in so far at 299 dollars to
people at that level after one day we
have raised six percent of the money uh
which is a fantastic start the campaign
will end not coincidentally very very
symbolically on january twentieth the
day that president-elect Donald Trump
will become president donald trump the
most popular perk selected so far
through the campaign is the 2017
calendar which i happen to have right
here autograph 2017 calendars the most
popular perks so far through the
campaign the second most popular perk so
far the david pakman show bumper
stickers which are available as i have
here in both white and black I don't
even know if we should be calling these
bumper stickers anymore really what they
are is macbook air stickers right i mean
i think our audience is much more likely
to put the bumper stickers on their
macbook air than they are on the bumper
of their car i'd imagine i think bumper
stickers are starting to go out of
fashion a little bit cuz they may leave
a little mark on the car yeah and we
know that also uh some people just don't
like to make themselves targets although
we've had many david pakman show viewers
meet each other because of bumper
stickers that have actually been on
bumpers and we've had the the opposite
of a road rage incident i'd call it a
road love incident triggered by a david
pakman show bumper-sticker so what is
the goal for today i'd like to engage
100 more donors if you hear this and you
say you know i'd like to support with
the david pakman show is doing and you
can read all about it at david
pakman.com slash donate but I really
can't donate more than a dollar or two
please do it because if we engage
another hundred donors even if it's at
one or two dollars each that really
helps us in the IndieGoGo algorithm uh
so please please PLEASE david pakman.com
slash donate even if it's a dollar or
two but I
love to get at least one donation today
that bests the campaign high of two
hundred ninety nine dollars so far last
thing even if you can't donate at all
the top five referrers of donors to the
campaign will get our two hundred ninety
nine dollar perk for free all you have
to do is make sure you're logged in to
indy gogo create an account for free in
a minute and then use the facebook and
twitter share buttons on the page to
share the campaign the system will track
donations that are made through your
posts and the top five refers during the
campaign will get the two hundred ninety
nine dollar perk for free this depends
on you help us to make it happen really
big goal I get it day one went
incredibly well and you can get help us
keep up the momentum at david pakman.com
slash donate